und wir schauen auf den nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt das ist der mit der
nummer vier ein antrag der spd-fraktion
es geht um die vereinbarkeit bzw wie die
afg sagt unvereinbarkeit von islam
scharia und rechtsstaat die fdp fraktion
fordert darin unter anderem die
bundesregierung auf geeignete maßnahmen
zu ergreifen um die verbreitung von im
koran enthaltenen gesetzwidrigen
inhalten und aufrufen zu unterbinden
das ist der ausschnitt der zitat aus dem
antrag der afd wie da die
bundesregierung allerdings im einzelnen
vorgehen soll und welche maßnahmen sie
ergreifen soll und in welchen bereichen
das lässt die afg auch in ihrem antrag
offen sodass wir gespannt sind auf
welcher ebene auch stilistisch diese
ganze debatte jetzt hier vonstatten
gehen wird der erste redner wird sein
gottfried curio ist der innenpolitische
sprecher der fdp-fraktion den der
bundestagspräsident jetzt auch gleich
ans pult bitten wird
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident geehrte
abgeordnete wir sehen religiös
motiviertes mobbing andersgläubiger
schüler durch muslimische mitschüler
wir sehen die herabsetzende behandlung
von frauen bis hin zu eifersucht und
ehrenmorden zwangs und kinder eben hier
sehen muslimische attentäter die allahu
akbar rufen wir sehen verfolgung und
todes bedrohung von liberalen muslimen
abdel-samad rushdie begründet von
höchsten islamischen autoritäten was bis
der gemeinsame hintergrund all dessen
liegt eine quasi natürliche
gewaltneigung vor
mitnichten dieser hass diese
respektlosigkeit diese niedrige schwelle
zur gewalt ist erlernt diese
kriminalität ist ideologisch legitimiert
kulturell eingeübt durch anweisungen
gebote aufrufe aufrufe aus dem
gründungsdokument einer religion
wer den islam aber allein als religion
versteht der missversteht ihn er ist
auch gesellschaftsordnung und gewalt
affine ideologie die die welt ein teilt
eine höherwertige gläubige und
minderwertig ungläubigen zu bekämpfen
sind etliche weisungen im koran rufen zu
straftaten auf wir hören da kriegs
aufrufe kämpft bis sämtliche verehrung
fall eingerichtet ist ja zu einen
gesandten mit der wahren religion
geschickt damit er sie über alle anderen
religionen siegen last tötet sie wo
immer ihr sie findet oder gewalt gegen
frauen wenn frauen sich aufnehmen
schlagt sie bis hin zur ehrlichen
vergewaltigung eure frauen sind für euch
einsatzfeld geht zu diesem saalfeld wann
und wie ihr wollt
wir hören religiöse diskriminierung
halle hat die ungläubigen verflucht und
für sie die flamme bereitet bis hin zur
volksverhetzung die ungläubigen sind die
schlechtesten der geschöpfe herr kollege
korea gestartet inzwischen frage nein
soweit solche gebote grundgesetz und
strafe sie haben gleich gelegenheit zu
antworten hören sie sich erstmal den
antrag an grundgesetz und
strafgesetzbuch widersprechen sind sie
nicht einfach durch freiheit der
religionsausübung geschützt diese hebt
mitnichten anderer rechts pflichten
einfach auf etwa die der treue zum recht
auf die strafbarkeit solcher text
stellen hinzuweisen wäre ein erster
schritt oder soll solche hetze jetzt
schulfach werden
so würden vor unseren augen neuer
gefährder produziert erleben wir jetzt
eine vollverschleierung für unser
grundgesetz
meine damen und herren heimeligen kurier
sie gestalten generell keine zwischen
die bei millionen von muslimen in
deutschland bei zigtausenden von
salafisten islamistischen gefährdern und
schon im kindesalter radikalisierten
muslim gefährden diese texte den inneren
frieden den viel berufenen zusammenhalt
zwei drittel der europäischen muslime
finden die vorschriften des koran
wichtiger als die landesgesetze unsere
forderung die verbreitung solcher
gesetzwidrigen inhalte zu unterbinden
gibt der bevölkerung die
rechtssicherheit die für ein
zusammenleben unabdingbar ist in seiner
uneingeschränkten gestalt gehört der
islam und die mit ihm untrennbar
verbundene scharia nicht zum rechtsstaat
deutschland
[Applaus]
der gedanke der religionsfreiheit steht
unserer forderung nicht entgegen die
freiheit der ausübung der religion ist
ja nicht lizenz zum bruch sonstiger
gesetze polygamie kinder ehe
zwangsheirat ehrenmord homophobie minder
berechtigung und züchtung der frau
antisemitismus christenverfolgung
steinigung enthauptung kalter krieg
findet ihre rechtfertigung ja ihren
grund in weisungen des islam
wer solche gesetzwidrigen aufrufe
aktuell propagiert macht sich strafbar
ihre religiöse herkunft ändert daran
nichts ganz nebenbei polygamie ist nicht
nur ungesetzlich sie ist auch unsozial
der neubürger holt seine zweite und
dritte frau nach der altburger darf sich
zur finanzierung in zweiter und dritter
suchen
meine damen und herren der einzelne
moslem mag sich von einem
verfassungsfeindlichen korsett
emanzipieren können der islam selbst
aber als gesellschaftliche ordnung steht
im wesentlichen inhalten unserer
verfassung wie auf der menschenrechts
karte entgegen erst in unsere
werteordnung nicht integrierbar etwa die
kairoer erklärung muslimischer staaten
sagt es gibt keine verbrechen und
strafen außerdem in der scharia
festgelegten und das demokratiedefizit
islamischer staaten ist kein zufall
sondern zwingend angelegt die türkei war
eine demokratie solange sie nicht
islamisch gesteuert wurde
seit sie unter erdogan re islamisiert
wird hört sie nicht zufällig auf eine
demokratie zu sein oder oder muss man
das alles nur anders deuten nein die
aufruf im koran sind unmittelbare gottes
worte deshalb ungültig im wortlaut
unveränderbar nicht durch
interpretationen relativierte der koran
sagt es gibt keinen der die worte allahs
zu ändern vermag und der einfache moslem
interpretiert nicht erhört die worte
betrifft ist vielleicht nur ein
islamismus nein wir ärgern sagt es gibt
keinen unterschied zwischen islam und
islamismus islamismus ist nur
angewandter islam islam gehört nicht zu
deutschland weil er nicht zu unserem
rechtsstaat gehört
kann ein toleranter islam ist westliches
wunschdenken euro islam deutscher islam
demokratischer islam sind leere
fantastereien von runden quadraten und
eckigen kreisen eine studie unter
muslimischen schülern in niedersachsen
zeigt 27 prozent halten die scharia für
besser als deutsche gesetze 19 halten es
für die pflicht jedes moslems ungläubige
zu bekämpfen und den islam auf der
ganzen welt zu verbreiten 8% für
ausbreitung des 4 prozent für
terroranschläge die verachtung
andersgläubiger ist genau die
einstellung aus der terrorismus entsteht
denn wer den lebensstil einer
gesellschaft radikal ablehnt sie als
sündig empfindet geht leichter
gewalttätig gegen sie vor alles amri
handelte in folge für seiner
legitimation durch den koran der in der
schule gelehrte koran und der von den
salafisten verteilte ist derselbe wäre
etwa dass jugendgefährdende medien heute
dasjenige wo ein reales killerspiel
geboten wird kein moslem sollte sich
mehr radikalisieren und für
gewaltverbrechen legitimiert führen
können durchgesetzt wieder gelernt deren
verbreitung sollte in deutschland nicht
länger erlaubt sein das ist jetzt ihre
verantwortung wir gegen diesen antrag
stimmt stimmt nicht etwa gegen die afd
er stimmt gegen das grundgesetz und
handelt gegen die sicherheit unserer
bürger
es gibt leute
es gibt leute die suggerieren wollen
gewalt im namen dieser religion habe
nichts mit dieser religion zu tun
aha wer bei seinem ort allahu akhbar
ruft meint dann wohl gar nicht allein
die prägenden ursachen zu verdrängen ist
denen wichtiger als die opfer wichtiger
als bedrängt durch homosexuelle
wichtiger als geschlagene juden
wichtiger als mit messerstichen
ermordeten frauen diese texte sind eben
nicht harmlos wie ihre wirkung zeigt
merkels einladungspolitik hat
hunderttausendfach judenhass nach
deutschland importiert nach verkaufs und
allen nie wieder spüren ist solche
regierung von antisemitismus eine
schande frau merkel
[Applaus]
ist das also merkels motto nach mir die
scharia alltägliche messer gewalt angst
räume für frauen für juden mobbing
deutscher schüler wachsende no go areas
all das gab es vor merkel nicht wenn
merkel meint der islam gehöre zu
deutschland gehöre zu unserem
rechtsstaat deutschland dann sagen wir
der islam gehört zu merkel
aber merkel dürfe nicht länger zu
deutschland ich danke gott schritt
choreo für die afg ist er
innenpolitischer sprecher und hat viele
zahlen genannt in seinem beitrag
allerdings ohne quellen so dass wir da
nicht recht wissen woher die kommen der
nächste redner ist patrick sensburg aus
der unionsfraktion über ernsthafte
themen diskutieren und debattieren will
der sollte erst einmal parlamentarischen
gepflogenheiten einhalten sollte erstmal
anträge so frühzeitig auch in den
parlamentarischen raum geben dass wir
sie gemeinsam intensiv lesen können
debattieren können und dann auch
diskutieren können und ganz interessant
ist ja dass gestern abend über ihren
antrag meine damen und herren von der af
d focus schon berichtet ich zitiere afd
provoziert im bundestag mit schlecht
vorbereiteten antrag gegen muslime
es geht dann weiter zitat die fdp
bundestagsfraktion will am donnerstag
eine stunde lang über den islam
diskutieren die parlamentarier der
übrigen fraktionen haben aber praktisch
keine chancen sich darauf vorzubereiten
denn einen tag vor der debatte lag der
antrag immer noch nicht vor zitat ende
das haben sie wohl auch gelesen als sie
dann ihr
den antrag noch einmal in der nacht von
gestern auf heute verändert haben 58 war
dann hochgeladen in der aktuellen form
58 vor der aktuellen debatte
da würde ich mir doch bitte ein bisschen
parlamentarische kollegialität wenn man
über ernsthafte themen reden möchte herr
kollege jens möckel stärken sie eine
zwischenfrage aber sehr gerne anders als
bei der afd
mögen wir die debatte hat der herr dr
sensburg nun ist es ja so dass cdu csu
und spd selbst auf die tagesordnung für
punkt 9 einen antrag zum europäischen
bildungsraum gesetzt haben der erst
gestern gegen 12 uhr verschickt worden
ist glauben sie dass der ansatz den die
union mit ihrer späten versendung
wichtiger themen oder halten sie den
europäischen bildungsraum nicht für ein
wichtiges thema glauben sie dass dieser
ansatz einer späten versendung bei der
union in irgendeiner weise besser
gerechtfertigt sei als in der ard
glauben sie dass sich eine fraktion an
die parlamentarische gepflogenheiten
halten muss während im wesentlichen in
diesem hause das ist eine große kritik
an alle fristen existieren
gepflogenheiten existieren die im
wesentlichen in jedem kreis tag besser
geregelt sind was hier an anträgen in
letzter minute rein kommt von allen
möglichen fraktionen kann nicht mehr
sinnvoll bearbeitet werden und deswegen
war eine frage an sie sie sind ja nun
schon länger hier sitzend wie bewerten
sie denn diese parlamentarischen
gepflogenheiten die die union selbst
pflegt der unterschied ist
und da sage ich ihnen auch als
vorsitzender der geschäftsführung des
ausschusses und mitglied des
ältestenrates dass wir den von ihnen
erwähnten antrag in den ausschüssen
intensiv debattiert haben und dass wir
den antrag der hier jetzt von der afg
eingebracht worden ist noch nichtmal
gestern im rechtsausschuss bei den
mitgliedern ihrer fraktion im
rechtsausschuss bekannt war
da können sie nicht den kopf schütteln
ich habe gestern im rechtsausschuss die
frage gestellt ob die mitglieder der kfd
im recht
schuss am gestrigen mittwoch den antrag
der afg kennen ob sie etwas dazu sagen
können weil ich hätte ihn gerne gehabt
als redner heute da haben ihre
fraktionsmitglieder im rechtsausschuss
gesagt dass sie ihn nicht kennen also
von daher der unterschied ist schon sehr
deutlich im ältestenrat diskutieren wir
regelmäßig über die verspätet
eingereichten anträge der afg in der
presse können sie inzwischen nachlesen
dass es anscheinend methode hat
vielleicht denken sie doch einmal über
ihre praxis nach wir alle denken über
die praxis nach dass wir die
gepflogenheiten einhalten 24 stunden vor
der debatte aber 58 am heutigen morgen
sind nicht 24 stunden und rechtfertigt
glaube ich auch nicht dieses ernsthafte
thema herr kollege james park in der
kollegen hören möchte auch nur eine
zwischenfrage stellen gerne gerne
inzwischen fragen
herzlichen dank des kollege sensburg
dass die die zwischenfrage zu lassen
als einer der sich persönlich sehr
betroffen fühlt von den worten auch des
kollegen der das gefühl hat um es jetzt
meinen sagen worten zu sagen es kann
sein dass einzelne afd mitglieder so tun
also würden sie zum grundgesetz steht
die aktuellen für sich steht nicht zum
grundgesetz habe ich habe ich 2
zwei fragen die wir ihm stellen konnten
die erste ist war die ganze zeit die
rede von der scharia
das sind ganz viele arten von scharia
unterwegs unser job hier ist dafür zu
sorgen dass die teile die mit dem
grundgesetz vereinbar sind auch
angewendet werden können und die nicht
die eben nicht aber es gibt zahlreiche
arten von scharia und ich frage mich
auch sehr direkte ausgabe meinte der was
er meint wenn der scharia sein wissen
sie wovon er redet und die zweite frage
ist die geschichte des islams ist eine
ganz lange geschichte von
interpretationsmöglichkeiten und es gab
bis ende des 19 jahrhunderts unter jedem
gutachten immer einen satz der hieß wie
es aber wirklich ist weiß nicht der
menschen oder nur der gott der gläubigen
jetzt gibt es zwei gruppen die
ausschließlich auf eine einzige art und
weise der interpretation rekurrieren das
sind die islamisten und das ist die afd
glauben sie auch dass die afg eigentlich
das spiel der islamisten spielt und dass
die einander brauchen bedanke mich ganz
herzlich für ihre zwischen frage und ich
habe mich bei dem antrag
als ich ihn gelesen habe den ersten
gestern abend heute morgen auch noch
einmal auch gefragt was ist die
zielrichtung
es wird weitgehend vermengt
durcheinandergeworfen es wird angst
geschürt es werden auch die
unterschiedlichen formen des islam seine
sunniten schiiten aleviten alle bieten
all das gar nicht differenziert das wäre
ja so als würde man bei der afg sagen
alle sind rechtsradikal alle sind
rechtsextremen das ist ja nicht der fall
das ist ja nicht der fall auch bei ihnen
gibt es zahlreiche vernünftige die
wahrscheinlich mit den anderen gar nicht
in einen topf geworfen werden wollen
da wird man sicherlich auch bei der afd
der meinung seien mit dem ein oder
anderen möchte ich nicht gleichgesetzt
werden wenn ich ihre unterschiedlichen
debatten in der fraktion erlebe also von
daher alles zusammen zu werfen zu
vermengen ist grundsätzlich falsch
und wenn ich dann noch sehr dass der
antrag der afd
eigentlich der alten partei wenn ich mal
ihren altersdurchschnitt sehe wenn ich
ihre politische erfahrung sie in
früheren parteien
sie sind ja politisch erfahren völlig
inhaltslos ist formal zu spät und sie
beantragen
zitat ihres antrags geeignete maßnahmen
sollen ergriffen werden von im koran
enthalten gesetzwidrigen inhalten und
aufrufe zu und diese zu unterbinden also
von daher wir reden von einem
christlichen allem religiösen
schriftstück aus dem sechsten
jahrhundert so undifferenziert etwas zu
beantragen ich habe eben mal dazwischen
berufen sollen jetzt hier text passagen
geschwärzt werden oder was stellen sie
sich vor das zeigt schon meine damen und
herren dass ihr antrag überhaupt nicht
debatten fähig ist
danke also für die zwischenfrage die afg
hätte ja übrigens in den vergangenen
jahren lösungsansätze bieten können da
ist nicht viel gekommen seid 2014
ich habe mal ihre unterschiedlichen
anträge rausgesucht hamburg zur parallel
justiz 2016 berlin 2017 zum islamischen
religionsunterricht der antrag ist
übrigens in weiten teilen wortgleich mit
diesem antrag
sie können das ja mal vergleichen dann
einen zum islamischen jugendzentrum
berlin 2018 und ein zur
parallelgesellschaft in nrw so seien aus
dem jahr 2018 das war's mehr habe ich
bei ihm nicht gefunden und sie selbst
nennen in ihrem antrag doch was man
machen könnte
sie nennen die paragraphen die wir haben
die aufgreifen § 111 steht in ihrem
antrag öffentliche aufforderung zu
straftaten
§ 126 steht in ihrem antrag störung des
öffentlichen friedens durch androhung
von straftaten
§ 185 steht in ihrem antrag beleidigung
paragraf 130 volksverhetzung § 172
doppel er steht alles in ihrem antrag
das instrumentarium das was wir haben
das greift das funktioniert und sie
haben selbst ja in ihrem antrag
beschrieben das ist ja das schräge und
wenn kollege dr curio von diesen
strafbarkeit und redet dann hat er sie
ja auch gesehen im eigenen antrag und
dann weiß er auch wir haben das
strafrechtliche instrumentarium um hier
dagegen zu wirken
und wir können auch über weitere dinge
reden die cdu hat das thema ja schon
viel viel länger als sie auf dem schirm
cdu und csu gemeinsam das sind zb wir
hören sie doch mal zu sie verstehen es
doch sonst gar nicht es sind zb fragen
der abschöpfung bei scharia richtern die
wir die geldzahlungen die zb im
planbereich dann gezahlt werden die wir
die abschöpfen können wir haben in den
letzten jahren eine vielzahl von
vereinsverboten gestützt auf die
rechtlichen grundlagen gehabt ich kann
es ihnen gar nicht vorlesen war meine
zeit zu kurz ich fange nun mal 2012 an
wir haben mit ibrahim verboten
unanfechtbar geworden wir haben da war
ffm einschließlich dateien organisation
internationaler jugend vor allem dadurch
abba tv verboten 2013 an uster 2013 da
war team islamische audios 213
waisenkinder projekt libanon ev 214 bei
verfassungswidrig islamistischen staat
214 david germany 215 die wahre religion
dwr 216 also das instrumentarium wirkt
wir könnten auch noch viel weiter gehen
und auch das machen wir in nrw
beispielsweise mit dem projekt wegweiser
ich weiß nicht ob sie das kennen
vielleicht die kollegen aus nrw wo wir
versuchen sehr frühzeitig der
radikalisierung entgegenzuwirken
das sind maßnahmen die bringen etwas
nicht spaltung
polarisierung nicht blinder populismus
und gegen religion wettern maßnahmen
bringen
und was hat die cdu in den letzten
jahren gemacht ein fraktions kongress im
jahre 2012 da haben sich die meisten von
ihnen mit dem thema noch gar nicht
beschäftigt zum thema islamistische
parallel justiz in deutschland eine
herausforderung für den rechtsstaat
wir hatten im jahre 2012 eine eigene
haushaltsstelle im haushalt des
bundesministeriums der justiz die sich
mit dem phänomen parallel justiz
beschäftigt hat 2016 ein weiterer
fraktions kongress im koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten illegale parallel justiz
werden wir nicht dulden auf seite 133
und meine damen und herren wenn sie sich
informieren wollen weil meine redezeit
ist jetzt zu ende lesen sie auf sätze
von mir nach zur neuen
kriminalitätsphänomen im zeichen der
parallelgesellschaft das ist deutsche
richter zeitung 216 zur
parallelgesellschaft 2015
meine damen und herren von der afg so
ein antrag geht nicht arbeiten sie im
parlament mit seien sie seriös mit ihren
an tragen wenn es wirklich um ernste
themen geht spalten sie nicht das land
sondern arbeiten sie gemeinsam an
lösungen mit zumindest die von ihnen die
das wollen danke schön
der cdu abgeordnete patrick sensburg
weist darauf hin dass zahlreiche
verfassungswidrige islamistische
organisationen in den vergangenen jahren
verboten worden sind das als replik auf
den fdp antrag der ja verlangt das so
heißt es wörtlich der radikalisierung
der boden entzogen wird und die
verbreitung gesetzwidriger lehrern
gestoppt werden soll
der nächste redner ist jürgen martens
aus der fdp fraktion und der orte
rechtspolitischer sprecher
wann ist dieser antrag den wohl
formuliert worden
ich will es nicht zeitlich eingrenzen
ich will es inhaltlich eingrenzen dieser
antrag
er kommt aus finstersten 8
die aussagen hören der koran als solches
gefährt inneren frieden dass es mich mal
mit etwas doch antikem entgegenhalten
du sollst nichts falsches gegen deinen
nächsten aussagen weil damit der antrag
heißt wirklich zitate aus dem koran 13
nebeneinander ohne irgendeine erklärung
ohne kontext ohne bezug ohne historische
erläuterung und das mit 1500 jahre alten
text teilen die aus einem anderen
anderen kulturhistorischen hintergrund
kommen das ist schon gewarnt meine damen
und herren wenn man damit aktuell
ernsthaft politik betreiben möchte und
das ganze soll dann belegen das wesen
des islam das verhalten aller gläubigen
muslime natürlich gleich aber das hat
mit den tatsächlichen verhältnissen in
diesem land auch in europa nichts zu tun
jede religion hat es verdient nach ihren
tatsächlichen erscheinen und handeln
nicht nach irgendwelchen zitaten aus
ihren grundlegenden schriften beurteilt
zu werden
also können wir das christentum auch mal
das ist ja seit 1500 jahren reichlich
gewalttätig gegen andersgläubige
unterwegs das wird sich nicht bestreiten
lassen
da gibt es zitate gewaltverherrlichung
frauenfeindliches und homophobe source
so spricht der herr sehe ich will
unglück bringen bringen in deinem
eigenen hause und will deine weiber vor
deinen augen nehmen und sie deinen
nächsten geben dass er bei deinen
weibern schlafen soll
der nichten sonne zweiter samuel kapitel
12 vers 1 oder was homophobie
wenn jemand mein mann liegt wie bei
einer frau so haben sie getan was ein
gräuel ist und bald sollen beide des
todes sterben drittes buch mose kapitel
20 vers 13
wenn da und herren wollen sie deswegen
vielleicht eine bereinigung inhalts
bereinigung der bibel verlangen
natürlich nicht sondern sie beschränken
sich hier auf den koran sie betreiben
islamophobe demagogie wenn etwa herr dr
curio hier davon spricht der islam sei
hintergrund kulturell ein guter
kriminalität herr kollege machens
gestalten sie eine zwischenfrage vielen
dank herr kollege dass sie zwischen
frage zu lassen wir müssen hier den
islam gar nicht nach dem koran bewerten
sondern können auch danach den wie er
sich in der welt zeigt es gibt 57
staaten die mehrheitlich muslimisch sind
in welchen davon würden sie denn gerne
leben und den welten davon ist die
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau so
hergestellt oder die gleichberechtigung
von homosexuellen heterosexuellen wie
hier
also in der tat ist in länder in denen
erhebliche fortschritte gemacht es sind
auch im hinblick auf die
rechtsstaatlichkeit in fassungslosigkeit
das ist richtig es gibt einige länder in
denen ich bestimmt nicht lieber es gibt
aber auch genügend
christlich-abendländisch geprägtes
länder in denen ich auch nicht leben
möchte meine damen und herren und wir
unterhalten uns und dieses land um die
bundesrepublik und die möchte ich so
sehen wie sie unser rechtsstaat und
unsere verfassung gestaltet hat und
nicht in dem sinne verändert wie sie
sich das vorstellen indem wir religiöse
schriften staatlicherseits am besten
auch noch mal verbieten oder eingrenzen
oder verändern lassen darunter stehen
lassen antwortet der rechtsstaat von dem
sie hier gesprochen haben dieser
rechtsstaat er muss sich ja er darf sich
nicht in der von ihnen gewünschten weise
betätigen religionsfreiheit bedeutet
dass du glauben kannst was du willst
aber handeln darfst du nur in den
grenzen des rechts meine damen und
herren
und jetzt es ist völlig egal ob ein
moslem seine ehefrau unter berufung auf
den koran schlägt oder ob ein
evangelikaler christ seine kinder unter
hinweis auf ein biblisches
züchtigungsrecht verprügelt beide
bekommen jetzt mit dem rechtsstaat zu
tun und zwar in gestalt des
staatsanwalts
und das wissen deswegen kommt dann im
antrag am ende nur diese hilflose
forderung die bundesregierung solle
geeigneten maßnahmen ergreifen die
verbreitung zu unterbinden
vulgo sie fordern ein koran verboten
meine damen und herren
aber das wäre so offenkundig
verfassungswidrig dass sie sich gar
nicht trauen das auszusprechen
sie vertrauen stattdessen darauf dass
das bei ihrer kundschaft als meter text
unausgesprochen ankommt und dass sie
sich einst sagen auch wenn die wahlen in
bayern kurz bevorstehen
sie wollen hier noch mal ein kracher
zünden meinetwegen aber sie ziehen
keinen kracher sie warfen einen
brandsatz
mitten in diese gesellschaft hinein und
das lassen wir ihnen nicht durchgehen
sie lösen keine probleme sind spalten
sieht die familie meine damen und herren
von der afg sie haben eine verantwortung
als abgeordnete und zwar für das gesamte
volk und dieser verantwortung werden sie
das zeigen sie überdeutlich in keiner
weise gerecht jürgen martens für die fdp
fraktion deren rechtspolitischer
sprecher und wird schon noch mal kurz
auf die zwischenfrage eben aus den
reihen der af.de da hieß es ja dass der
islam frauen und männer nicht
gleichberechtigt und es wurde auch
kritisiert dass homosexuelle auch nicht
gleich behandelt werden da hilft
vielleicht ein kurzer blick auf das was
die kfd als antrag heute noch
eingebracht hat in den bundestag und
dieser antrag sieht nämlich vor dass die
er für alle wieder aufgehoben wird da
muss man sich dann auch erstmal ein reim
drauf machen der nächste redner am pult
ist frith ist pardon ist karl heinz
brunner aus der spd-fraktion er ist
mitglied im ausschuss für recht und
verbraucherschutz platzieren muss diesen
geschwätz etwas entgegengesetzt werden
kolleginnen und kollegen vielleicht ist
dem einen oder anderen aufgefallen dass
da auf dieser wunderschönen wand rechts
und links als überschrift zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt vermutlich als
freundschaft versprecher islam steht
aber dieses hohe haus hat wieder die
aufgabe noch die zuständigkeit eine
religionspolitische debatte zu führen
oder gar als religionspolizei wie wir
sie aus anderen ländern kennen sich zu
gerieren
sie suggerieren mit ihrem antrag ganz
bewusst ganz subtil dass in unserem land
parallel justizsysteme bestehen würden
und unser rechtsstaat auf den wir alle
nicht nur setzen sondern auf denen wir
vertrauen können
dieser rechtsstaat in diesem land nicht
gelte dazu haben wir diesen rechtsstaat
dazu haben wir regelungen die sind gut
die sind richtig und die sind notwendig
und ich sage ganz deutlich wenn hier
dieser antrag den ich fast als
putzlappen bezeichnen hätte der nur auf
vermutungen diffusen ängsten und keinen
qualitativen studien beruht nachdem der
autor der einzigen studie die bezogen
ist selbst betont dass nur in die
minderheit deutscher muslime überhaupt
fundamentalistische einstellung hat dann
haben sie bewusst heute die unwahrheit
behauptet mit diesem antrag und das
bezeichnet man in diesem land lüge sage
ja aber rechnerisch gerade deshalb weil
sie es tatsächlich fertig bringen
innerhalb von zwei wochen einmal die
religionsfreiheit in frage zu stellen
als nächstes wollen sie in dieser woche
die idee für alle wieder aufheben
und dann homophobie in diesem haus als
kronzeugen auch führen der für dafür
herhalten sollte eine religion in diesem
lande von der religionsfreiheit
auszuschließen
das geht nicht das darf nicht sein nur
das dürfen wir ihnen nicht durchgehen
lassen
meine kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
aber in diesem land
parallelgesellschaften das stellen wir
heute fest wir haben
parallelgesellschaften die auch mit
staatlichen herr kollege bonner der
kollege haben möchte gerne eine
zwischenfrage stellen ehe das will ich
jetzt nicht weil ich überhaupt keine
wir haben parallelstrukturen nämlich
diejenigen die althergebrachte
traditionen in diesem land viel
wichtiger halten als den rechtsstaat
wichtige halten heißt unsere verfassung
wir haben menschen und strukturen in dem
land ihr unter dem ständigen psychischen
sozialen druck stehen dass sie angeblich
als inländer ausgegrenzt sein
wir haben kriminalstatistiken die zeigen
dass dieser personenkreis und diese
gruppe ansteigen
wir wissen dass das auftreten den guten
manieren widerspricht und unserem
christlich abendländischen traditionen
schon zwei mal ein blick nach chemnitz
zeigt es deutlich
sie leben in ständiger furcht vor
anderen minderheiten von homosexuellen
von migranten von juden vor frauen und
und ich glaube auch für uns
parlamentarierin obama italien
und obwohl sie angst und sogar in
manchen teilen gewalt verbreiten schauen
in diesem land noch viel zu viele
menschen schlichtweg diese armen
geschöpfe möchte ich jetzt sagen bringen
einiges durcheinander
lassen sie uns deshalb nicht wegschauen
lassen sie uns zusammen stehen gegen
diese wöchentliche hetze in diesem haus
und diesem land und da sitzt die sätze
wissen sie
wir haben es ja nun mit anträgen zu tun
die aus meiner sicht offen rassistisch
sind und was besonders wichtig ist
undemokratisch
sie werfen eine gesellschaftsgruppe mal
pauschal eben vor nicht recht und
verfassung zu achten
sie unterstützen nicht sondern sie
hintertreiben die integrationsarbeit die
gute arbeit unserer polizei unsere
justiz die eigentlich unsere
unterstützung benötigt sie nehmen
scheinlösungen wie es ihnen in den kram
passt sie wollen keine religionsfreiheit
keine religionsfreiheit sondern eine
religionspolizei und deshalb sage ich
ganz deutlich mir ist es persönlich
schon leid mich mit diesem mist ständig
zu belassen
wir sollten nun auch sie endlich zudem
kommen wozu wir hier vom deutschen volk
entsandt sind ordentliche arbeit im
arbeits parlament der bundesrepublik
deutschland im deutschen bundestag zu
tun
vielen dank jetzt der theilig dem
abhören und hamburg steht das wort 200
zwischen den nationen herr doktor unna
um auf den mist zurückzukommen
gerade angesprochen haben ich habe den
eindruck dass sie einen großen teil
diesem hause eine realitätsverweigerung
stattfindet
und vielleicht auch in ihren reihen und
das ich mir ein grad vorher regner da
ein bisschen für aufhellungen zu sorgen
während sie bereit ein gemeinsames
treffen mit denen zwischen hunderten
tausenden angehörigen der opfer familien
diesen standpunkt denen noch mal was sie
gerade hier dargestellt hatten
auseinanderzusetzen ich glaube da hören
die andere töne als gemäßigte töne
derartige auf diese mauer
herr kollege bonner möchten sie
antworten sonderteil ich als nächsten
redner dem wort das überhaupt dem
kollegen friedrich straetmanns fraktion
die linke sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrte damen und herren auf den
tribünen zur beratung steht der antrag
der fdp fraktion der islam und die
angeblich untrennbar mit ihm verbundene
sharia wieder ein antrag der spät kam
und der dem parlament am besten erspart
geblieben wäre
ein antrag dessen ziel und präzise
mehren dort zwischen religions- politik
und berufung auf rechtsstaatlichkeit
konzentrieren wir uns für die analyse
dieses antrages einmal auf letzteres
dieser antrag zeigt mal wieder die afg
hat tiefgreifende probleme unsere
rechtsstaatliche ordnung zu verstehen
dabei erfassen wird ihre mitglieder noch
nahezu täglich selbst mit dem austesten
der rechtlichen grenzen und sollten
erfahrung damit haben viele rechter
verfährt
deshalb sollten auch sie inzwischen die
definition der demokratischen
grundprinzipien ebenso verstanden haben
wie die frage was in diesem land erlaubt
und was verboten ist wenn die
initiatoren des antrags das selbst nicht
wussten könnte eventuell herbrand noch
versuchen eine kleine vorlesung dazu zu
halten
herbrand massen haben befindet sich auf
diesem juristisch mangelhaften antrag
nicht warum das was sie als agent
formulieren ist nicht überflüssig
angesprochen wurde durch das
bundesministerium des inneren wurden 20
vereinsverbot den letzten jahren
ausgesprochen
sieht so fehlende aktivität aus wo nicht
belästigen sie uns mit einem schlampigen
antrag den sie aus durchsichtigen auf
ihre ideologie fußenden gründen stellen
vielleicht versuchen sie es zur
abwechslung mal mit der realität
das grundgesetz der bundesrepublik
deutschland gibt da klare hinweise
artikel 4 des grundgesetzes die freiheit
des glaubens des gewissens und die
freiheit des religiösen und des
weltanschaulichen bekenntnisses sind
unverletzlich
daraus folgt das staatliche
neutralitätsgebot an die
religionsgemeinschaft darf ihren glauben
nach innen leben soweit dies ohne zwang
und im einklang mit der rechtsordnung
geschieht mehr noch es ist den
staatlichen stellen untersagt
glaubensinhalte vor dem hintergrund
eines verbots als richtig oder falsch zu
bewerten
selbst wenn diese mit grundlegenden
verfassungsprinzipien in widerspruch
stehen
aber sobald jemand aus seiner religion
verhalten abschneidet das mit der
rechtsordnung des grundgesetzes im
widerspruch steht findet das grundrecht
der freien religionsausübung eine
unüberwindliche schranke in der
allgemeinen rechts auto ich darf hier zu
meinen früheren bielefelder
staatsrechtslehrer und
verfassungsrichter professor doktor
grimm in der faz vom 22 04 2016 zitieren
kein glaube muss mit dem grundgesetz
vereinbar seien
aber nicht alles was an glaube fordert
darf unter dem grundgesetz verwirklicht
werden mit dem vierten tag sagten
dürften doch die menge des antrages
offensichtlich sein
sie hätten sich entscheiden müssen
rechtlich oder der justiz zu
argumentieren kleid es ist ihnen mesloh
es ist eine frechheit den bundestag mit
einem solchen wirren antrag zu
überziehen auch an alpha wie sie hervor
jung sollte sich zumindest die mühe
machen anhand der existierenden
rechtsordnung zu argumentieren
vielen dank fröhlich stratmanns für die
linksfraktion mit sachdienlichen
hinweisen für anträge die im deutschen
bundestag eingebracht werden und die
nächste rednerin in dieser debatte ist
vieles polat aus der fraktion bündnis 90
grüne sie ist der sprecherin für
migrations- und integrationspolitik
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der antrag der fdp stellt eine ganze
glaubensgemeinschaft unter
generalverdacht sie stellt das
grundrecht auf religionsfreiheit in
frage
solche anträge meine damen und herren
und das haben wir auch in der rede
gehört des kollegen sind voller hetze
und rassismus und sind brandgefährlich
auf worte folgen oft abscheuliche taten
meine damen und herren das wurde noch
nicht gesagt das feindbild islam und
muslime sind seit geraumer zeit eine
wichtige bindekraft der rechtsradikalen
und des rechtspopulismus in ganz europa
geworden meine damen und herren und die
folge viele muslime werden zunehmend
diskriminiert und ausgegrenzt viele
muslime fühlen sich bedroht in unserem
land jeder dritte ist opfer jede drittes
opfer von diskriminierung
allein im jahr 2017 gab es nach angaben
des bundesministerium des inneren 1069
angriffe auf muslime oder muslimische
einrichtungen helgoland der großteil
aller politisch motivierten delikte sind
doch rechte straftaten von der
gesamtzahl von fast 40.000 straftaten im
jahr 2017 wurden 20.000 520 fälle
rechtsextremisten zugeordnet moscheen
werden mit schweineblut beschmiert oder
angezündet
meine damen und herren sie gehen ihren
antrag genauso vorn das wurde auch schon
gesagt wie die diese immer kritisieren
wie die islamisten selbst ihr islam bild
ihre lesart und ihre zitierweise des
sudan sind so schriftlich wie ein
salafistischer prediger
ich verweise hier auch ein potpourri von
koran zitaten und genau wie ein salafist
leugnen auch sie die notwendigkeit der
historischen exegese auch des islam
sie ignorieren die vielfalt des
islamischen lebens und der islamischen
theologie nicht zuletzt auch in
deutschland sie sagen islamistische
attentäter berufen sich zur
rechtfertigung ihrer taten auf den islam
beziehungsweise gebote des koran aber
meine damen und herren andreas beck
bezeichnete sich auch als 100
prozentigen christen das allein ist kein
argument für ihre kruden thesen der
kulturtreff der kulturkampf gegen die ft
mit ihrem herr antrag heraufbeschwört
ist kein mittel des rechtsstaates
sondern verstößt seinerseits diametral
gegen unsere grundwerte gegen die
menschenrechte
die freiheit und gleichheit rechte
unseres landes der inquisitorische eifer
ihres antrages ist mittelalterlicher
bauland ich frage mich deshalb dass der
antrag eigentlich und das wurde auch
schon gesagt unter geeigneten maßnahmen
die religiösen inhalte zu unterbinden
verstehen mag die die bundesregierung
ergreifen soll
glühende kohlen und daumenschrauben bis
zum absperren von koran meine damen und
herren
aber mal im ernst ihre forderung nach
der unterbindung der verbreitung
religiöser inhalte auch innerhalb der
religionsgemeinschaft geht erkennbar und
weit über die regelungen in artikel 140
grundgesetz hinaus glaubensinhalte
können nicht untersagt werden
sondern ausschließlich handlungen von
religionsgemeinschaften und tier ist der
deutsche rechtsstaat ganz klar das haben
die kollegen auch gerade von der linken
deutlich gemacht wer im namen von wem
auch immer aggressiv kämpferisch gegen
die rechtsordnung vorgeht der gegen
gesetze verstößt wer sich strafbar macht
wird dafür mit rechtsstaatlichen mitteln
zur verantwortung gezogen da kann sich
niemand hinter der religionsfreiheit
verstecken
meine damen und herren muslimas und
muslime davon viele mit deutscher
staatsbürgerschaft sind seit langer zeit
selbstverständlich bestandteil des
sozialen und kulturellen miteinanders in
deutschland auch in diesem parlament im
übrigen deutschland ist ein religiös und
weltanschaulich vielfältiges land und
das ist auch gut so das müssen wir
schützen meine damen und herren und das
müssen wir schützen nicht vor dem islam
sondern ich glaube vor ihnen
wir müssen ethnischen und religiösen wir
müssen ethnischen und religiösen
minderheiten in unserem land anerkennung
und wertschätzung begegnen meine damen
und herren ich wünsche mir und unsere
fraktion wünscht sich mehr austausch und
die bereitschaft zur gegenseitigen
akzeptanz ein starkes bekenntnis zu
einer solidarischen gesellschaft und ein
gemeinsames suchen nach antworten für
die herausforderung einer
multireligiösen aber säkularen
gesellschaft und dafür werden wir im
übrigen in berlin am samstag wieder mit
tausenden menschen auf die straße gehen
meine damen und herren wir sind mehr wir
sind und teil war ich danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
filiz polat aus den reihen der fraktion
bündnis 90 grüne hat nochmal auf eine
große demonstration an diesem sonnabend
in berlin hingewiesen wie den titel
unteilbar trägt der nächste redner
er ist alexander hoffmann aus der
unionsfraktion sehr geehrter herr
präsident geschätzt die kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren in hitziger debatte erleben wir
heute
einen typischen afd antrag mit heißer
nadel gestrickt kurz vor knapp auf die
schreibtische gekommen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen warum schlägt
der puls
ich habe ja noch gar nicht richtig
anfangen und weil das regelmäßig
passiert bei ihren anträgen
es ist nämlich nicht so dass das jetzt
einmal passiert ist sondern im
rechtsausschuss erleben wir dass
regelmäßig will ich grundsätzlich mal
was dazu sagen denn es gibt eigentlich
nur zwei möglichkeiten entweder sie
machen das aus voller absicht
dann muss man aber sagen dann liegt
ihnen offensichtlich sacharbeit nicht am
herzen
der zweite grund könnte allerdings sein
dass es ihnen in ihrer fraktion
schlichtweg an leistungsfähigkeit
mangelt am ende des tages will ich sagen
ist es eigentlich egal
weil beides wäre eine erklärung dafür
warum sie hier bislang noch nicht durch
qualitativ hochwertige sacharbeit
aufgefallen sind
es gibt doch ein zweites kennzeichen
woran man den fdp-antrag erkennt es
genügt ein blick in die überschrift eine
überschrift zwei zeilen und eigentlich
schon zwei falschbehauptungen ich will
konkret wer in der ersten hälfte sagen
sie die scharia ist untrennbar mit dem
islam verboten
und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
vielleicht haben sie es nicht
mitbekommen aber wir haben über vier
millionen muslime in diesem land und ein
großteil von denen hat mit dem
scharia-recht überhaupt nichts zu tun
es ist ihnen nicht einmal bekannt im
übrigen ist es so dass die scharia
selbst davon ausgeht dass es einen
regelwerk ist das dem wandel unterworfen
ist auch das haben sie
akorri um vergessen zu erwähnen und dann
kommt eigentlich der oberhammer
sie fangen an und lesen verse aus der
suche vor
und da kann ich sie eigentlich noch
fragen der kollegen satz heute schon
gemacht kennen sie eigentlich die bibel
wer die bibel kennt der weiß dass da zb
im dritten buch mose imf erst 20 steht
ein mann der mit der frau seines
nächsten de bricht wird mit dem tode
bestraft der ehebrecher samt der
ehebrecherin und in matthäus 15 steht
der vater oder mutter verflucht soll mit
dem tod bestraft werden und auch dort
ist es so dass sie letztendlich die
realität ausblenden oder sie vielleicht
besser verschweigen weil ich gehe davon
aus dass viele von ihnen wissen wie der
koran zu lesen ist wie die bibel zu
lesen ist und wie zum beispiel auch die
thora zu lesen ist nämlich immer zu
lesen und sie verstehen im lichte ihrer
zeit und stattdessen herr curio spalten
sie hier hetzen hier
sie machen stimmung und am ende haben
sie nicht einmal den schneid eine
zwischenfrage zuzulassen
jetzt kommen wir zur zweiten hälfte ihre
überschrift das sagen sie dann islam und
sharia haben den rechtsstaat keinen
platz sage ich wahnsinn
sie formulieren eine
selbstverständlichkeit für die ich für
meinen teil
die afd nicht gebraucht hätte denn der
kollege sensburg hat vorhin ausgeführt
das beschäftigt uns in der deutschen
politik gerade weil wir es nicht auf die
leichte schulter nehmen und gerade weil
wir es nicht klein reden wollen
schon seit jahren auch ich habe
irgendeine kleine liste mitgebracht es
gibt seit 2011 die arbeitsgruppe
parallel justiz im übrigen eine
bayerische initiative
das thema ist schon mehrfach
thematisiert worden auf der agenda der
justizministerkonferenz es gibt ein
bayerisches integrationsgesetz da gibt
es einen artikel 14 nämlich das
unterlaufen der verfassungsmäßigen
ordnung und auch hier in diesem haus
haben wir uns massiv mit all diesen
fragen beschäftigt ich darf nur erinnern
an die letzte diskussion zur frage der
nichtigkeit von kinder eben auch eine
lösung die wir erzeugen konnten ohne
dass wir sie dazu gebracht
und wenn wir dann gerade vor dem
hintergrund es nicht kleinzureden nach
bestimmten vorfällen schauen wie die
scharia polizei in wuppertal dann
erkennen wir dadurch auch dass der
rechtsstaat höchstwahrscheinlich sehr
gut funktioniert die urteile des
landgerichts wuppertal
die sind vom bgh aufgehoben worden wir
werden das sehr genau hinschauen ob es
noch regelungslücken gibt aber ich
glaube dass man diesen thema sachlich
begegnen sollte weil wir
zugegebenermaßen in schwierigen zeiten
leben aber in diesen schwierigen zeiten
sollten wir alle hier eine gemeinsame
mission haben nämlich die gesellschaft
nicht zu spalten und haben sie heute
leider einen ganz anderen eindruck
hinterlassen
vielen dank alexander hoffmann aus der
unionsfraktion in der debatte und jetzt
gibt es doch noch mal eine
kurzintervention vor dem ersten
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer bernd
baumann noch mal eine sache
klarzustellen ist hier mehrfach die mär
verbreitet worden
der antrag der sehr spät eingegangen der
ist am dienstag übermittelt worden an
die parlamentsdienste das lässt sich
nachweisen über e mails dass keine
erfindung im raum sind gestern ist der
titel noch mal auf intervention der
parlamentsdienste geändert worden aber
der
antrag ist am dienstag rom gegangen ich
weiß nicht warum warum warum machen sie
solche einwürfe oder haben sie keine
argumente mehr dass sie mit solchen
schiffen darstellen und jeder
vorbeikommen
[Applaus]
sie haben das wozu erwiderung
vielen dank frau präsidentin der kollege
sensburg hat auch vorhin sehr schön die
zeitschiene dieses antrags skizziert und
da gibt es nur zwei möglichkeiten das
was sie machen sie bezichtigen in ihr
offensichtlich der lüge hat sogar mit
uhrzeit benannt und ich habe ja dann und
es ist ihnen vielleicht auch entgangen
nicht nur über diesen antrag geredet
sondern darüber dass regelmäßig im
rechtsausschuss die anträge kurz vor
knapp ohne irgendeine chance auf
vorbereitung eingehen teilweise ist uns
nur der titel oder die überschrift
bekannt und das was ich dort anmahne ist
dass das ja auch kein kollegialer umgang
ist weil wenn es ihnen an der sacharbeit
liegen würde dann würden sie anträge
frühzeitig auf den tisch legen und auch
für ihre positionen werden und zu
überzeugen den dialog mit uns führen und
auf grund dieser kurzfristigkeit hand
ich eigentlich nur von einem spielchen
ausgehen danke so da haben wir nochmal
das thema wann ist eigentlich dieser afg
antrag eingebracht worden wann hat er
die anderen parlamentarier vor in den
rechtsausschuss erreicht da gibt es wohl
unterschiedliche auffassungen die
nächste rednerin zu diesem antrag ist
linda teuteberg aus der fdp-fraktion da
ist die migrationspolitische sprecherin
antrag die möchte ich gar nicht mehr
aufmerksamkeit und redezeit schenken
hier in diesem hohen hause
es stellen sich wahrlich ernste fragen
rund um das thema rechtsstaat und werte
unseres grundgesetzes in der
einwanderungsgesellschaft wie steht es
um das gewaltmonopol des staates um die
konsequente durchsetzung von geltendem
recht gegenüber jedermann allein zur
beantwortung dieser fragen trägt ihr
antrag herzlich wenig bei uns
nun wird in diesem zusammenhang oft und
gerne das wort verfassungspatriotismus
benutzt und es ist beinahe zu schön um
wahr zu sein alle scheinen sich da einig
zu sein und das ist für sich genommen
schon ein indiz dass es so einfach nicht
sein kann
ein defizit der aktuellen debatte um
werte besteht darin dass darin der
verfassung oft auch ein unveränderlicher
zeitloser gehalt unterstellt wird
aber sie ist auch offen für
entwicklungen und wir müssen uns immer
wieder neu auseinandersetzen um konkrete
fragen nach den werten unseres
grundgesetzes zu beantworten und deshalb
berufen sich nicht ohne nicht zufällig
auch immer wieder bei strittigen fragen
die ehe für alle ist ein beispiel
befürworter und gegner gleichermaßen auf
widerstreitende verfassungsgrundsätze
auf grundrechte und dann ist eine
abwägung zu treffen aber die es nur
bedingt juristisch vorstrukturiert das
grundgesetz es ersetzt keine debatten
ein ernst gemeinter
verfassungspatriotismus der ist viel
anspruchsvoller als es scheint er beruht
nicht nur auf unverrückbaren inhalten
sondern erfordert von uns ein die
bereitschaft zur inhaltlichen
auseinandersetzung und was wir brauchen
ist eine ernsthafte debatte darüber wie
wir zusammenleben wollen und was wir
unter integration verstehen darüber was
wir von menschen erwarten die mit uns
zusammen leben wollen und diejenigen die
sich integrieren wollen übrigens die
fragen auf danach da gibt es übrigens
viele spannende fragen die wir
beantworten müssen die leider in ihrem
antrag nicht angesprochen werden
wie weit reicht eigentlich der
schutzbereich der religionsfreiheit und
zwar individuell für den einzelnen wie
kollektiv für die religionsgemeinschaft
wie finden wir gesprächspartner wenn
andere religion anders verfasst sind als
die christlichen kirchen mit denen es
ein geübtes religionsverfassungsrecht
gibt und vieles weitere wo endet die
privatsphäre in der jeder nach seiner
facon selig wird und auch seinen
individuellen glauben auslebt wo beginnt
die zivil- oder gar öffentliche sphäre
vor recht und gesetz das verhalten
bestimmen das alles ist spannend aber
das beantworten sie nicht lassen sie uns
bei dieser wichtigen debatte die wir
der europäischen aufklärung übrigens
konsequent und gegenüber jedermann
anwenden
religionen sind zu respektieren sie
dürfen aber auch kritisiert werden und
nicht jede islam-kritik ist schon islam
und den mut zu dieser wichtigen
auseinandersetzung den wünsche ich mir
übrigens auch von manchen auf der linken
seite den sie gegenüber den christlichen
kirchen zeigen auch im gespräch mit
muslimen die voraussetzungen für ein
zusammenleben in offenen gesellschaft
ist auch der mut zum kritischen dialog
nur so kann verständnis füreinander und
auch für gemeinsame werte und regeln
entstehen wir brauchen diese debatte mit
selbstvertrauen mit gelassenheit mit
zuversicht nicht hasserfüllt und nicht
hysterisch sondern mit respekt vor den
anderen allerdings auch mit nicht
weniger respekt vor den eigenen werten
und überzeugungen vielen dank linda
teuteberg migrationspolitische
sprecherin der fdp-fraktion mit der
grundsätzlichen bei einem vermieter
grundsätzlichen beitrag zum thema
verfassung und verfassungsvertrag ismus
johannes fechner aus der spd fraktion
ist der nächste redner
einmal mehr zeigt die afg mit diesem
antrag das ist ihr tatsächlich nicht um
die sicherheit unserer bürgerinnen und
bürger geht der afg geht es nur darum
pauschal alle muslime als gewalttäter zu
verunglimpfen einmal mehr geht es ihnen
in der afg nur darum gegen flüchtlinge
und muslime zu hetzen und das lassen wir
ihnen auch heute nicht durchgehend liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in ihrem antrag
da machen sie glauben die sharia würde
in deutschland gelten und vor allem die
mehrheit der muslime würde der cherry
auf folgen aber das ist völliger unsinn
in deutschland gilt das grundgesetz
das ist auch gut so in deutschland gilt
die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das zeigt sich etwa am fall der
sogenannten scharia police in wuppertal
dort hatten sich in wuppertal einige
männer als
scharia police bezeichnet und
patrouillierten in den straßen
und dann gab es in der tat erst
juristische unklarheiten aber jetzt ist
es klar nach einer entscheidung des
bundesgerichtshof wer in deutschland
sich als scharia polizei bezeichnet und
patroulliert der macht sich strafbar und
das zeigt sich ganz klar und deutlich
zeigt das dass die scharia als
rechtsgrundlage in deutschland überhaupt
keine chance hat bei uns gilt der
rechtsstaat der wert sich unter
funktioniert und an diesem einfachen
beispiel zeigt sich es gelten bei uns
die werte unseres grundgesetzes
auch haben wir die kinder ihnen verboten
wir dulden keine parallel biscuits und
vor allem gewalttaten verfolgen er und
zwar egal ob sie von islamisten
rechtsradikalen oder linksradikalen
verübt werden liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und besonders besonders
bemerkenswert finde ich dass gerade die
afg unsere sicherheit und unseren
rechtsstaat durch die scharia bedroht
sieht ich finde die sicherheit in
unserem land ist doch eher bedroht durch
eine partei durch eine fraktion die in
ihren reihen einen staatsanwalt duldet
dem wegen hetze der beamten status
aberkannt wurde
die in ihren reihen ein verurteilten
gewalttäter duldet die in thüringen
einen landtagsabgeordneten dulden
beerdigen betrug verurteilt wurde und in
brandenburg wegen steuerhinterziehung so
etwas bedroht die freiheitliche
demokratische grundordnung viel mehr als
die scharia liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und der gipfel der verlogenheit
das ist es dass sie in diesem antrag vor
islamistischen gewalttaten waren gerade
sie die sie seit an seit mit neonazis
und rechtsradikalen in chemnitz und
anderswo seit an seit marschieren klären
sie erst mal ihr verhältnis zu
rechtsradikalen gewalttätern bevor sie
muslimin gewalttaten vorwerfen
meine damen und herren von der
die größere bedrohung für die sicherheit
sind mit sicherheit sie nicht die
scharia in deutschland und wenn ihnen
dieses thema tatsächlich wichtig wäre
wenn sie es tatsächlich nicht nur auf so
ankommen lassen würden dann würden sie
eigene vorschläge bringen stattdessen
betteln sie hier nur kraftlos die
bundesregierung an irgendwelche
maßnahmen die aus ihrer sicht notwendig
sein sollen zu präsentieren sie bringen
keine eigenen vorschläge und das liegt
daran weil sie auf genau wissen es gibt
keinen grund sich zu sorgen dass die
scharia in deutschland nennenswerten
einfluss hat wir haben einen starken
rechtsstaat und das ist auch gut so
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben in der letzten wahlperiode
eine menge an gesetzen gemacht wir haben
die kinder ebene verboten wir haben die
gesetze gegen islamistischen terrorismus
verschärft wir haben beim
generalbundesanwalt zur bekämpfung von
islamistischem terror neue stellen
geschaffen und all das zeigt wir wehren
uns gegen terrorismus und extremismus
und zwar egal von welcher politischen
seite deutschland ist eine wehrhafte
demokratie von wo auch immer der angriff
kommt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
schließlich sie kritisieren in ihrem
antrag dass die bundesregierung sich
nicht klar genug zur scharia und zum
islam äußern würde
und das ist völliger unsinn ich möchte
die bundesjustizministerin katarina
barley aus der zeit zitieren sie hat
dort im märz das ganz klar auf den punkt
gebracht ich zitiere der staat setzt das
recht darüber gibt es keine zwei
meinungen klarer kann man es nicht auf
den punkt bringen und deshalb ist auch
in dieser hinsicht ihr antrag vollkommen
unnötig liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der afg antrag will muslime pauschal als
scharia gläubige gewalttäter abstempeln
und er hat nur zum ziel vorurteile gegen
muslime zu befeuern
dem ist in aller deutlichkeit zu
widersprechen auch wenn es in
deutschland islamistische bedrohung und
terrorismus gibt die große mehrheit der
muslime lebt anständig bei uns deshalb
hören sie auf das friedliche
zusammenleben der menschen in
deutschland mit derart unzähligen
anträgen zu stören und das zusammenleben
der menschen zu behindern indem sie die
menschen gegeneinander aufhält vielen
dank der rechtspolitische sprecher der
spd fraktion johannes fechner hat noch
mal darauf hingewiesen dass vieles was
die afg in ihrem antrag fordert ohne es
genau zu beschreiben in den vergangenen
jahren durch die bundesregierung
umgesetzt worden ist nächste rednerin in
dieser debatte die sich mit einem antrag
der fdp beschäftigt ist die
religionspolitische sprecherin der links
fraktion christine buchholz und die
einzige forderung des antrags läuft
faktisch auf ein verbot des koran raus
sie sprechen damit muslimen die
grundrechte ab ihr antrag und die rede
von der kurie sind nichts als hetze im
schnitt gibt es jeden tag zwei islam
faltige straftaten in deutschland nach
experten durch die zahl aufgrund der
hohen dunkelziffer bis zu acht mal hören
und es ist der hass den die ard sieht
der zu dieser gewalt führt und ich sage
ihnen die menschenrechte ist unteilbar
die linke verteidigt die
religionsfreiheit für alle menschen in
diesem land gut führt die afd
koran zitate an um ihre hetze mit pseudo
argumenten zu unterlegen
und tatsächlich finden sich an vielen
stellen und dann stellen viele
religionen passagen die als
rechtfertigung von unterdrückung und
gewalt auslegbar sind so in der bibel im
alten wie im neuen testament im buch
mose lesen wir tötungs aufrufe die
offenbarung des johannes sieht ungläubig
und andere in einem pool der mit feuer
und schwefel brennt aber niemand kommt
hier auf die idee deshalb die bibel
verbieten zu wollen
zu recht sagt er und grinst den islam
nach derselben methode wie antisemiten
früher und auch heute das judentum
verleugnet haben indem sie einzelne
zitate aus dem kontext gerissen haben um
die gesamte religion zu diffamieren
so behauptete unter anderem der
katholische theologe conrad martin ende
des neunzehnten jahrhunderts der ganze
talmud sei das ein zeugnis des hasses
gegen nichtjuden ins unsere gegen
christen wohin solche verunglimpfungen
geführt haben wissen wir
und es ist kein zufall dass nicht nur
die reden und artikel von herrn gauland
denen eines hitlers immer ähnlicher
werden
und mit allem was die afc hier von sich
gibt beweist die übrigen nichts anderes
als ihre unkenntnis über den islam
es gibt nicht in einen islam und
selbstverständlich verändert sich der
islam im ständig und auch die scharia
ist einem wander und verschiedene
interpretationen unterlägen sie ist eine
sammlung von gottesdienstlichen
ethischen und normativen aspekten und
bestimmungen und halt kein
strafgesetzbuch und im übrigen ist auch
keine einzige relevante muslimische
organisation die forderte scharia in
deutschland einzuführen ist eine
geisterdebatte
die afg beschwört eine bedrohung durch
den islam heraus aber die wirkliche
gefahr kommt von der afg die die
faschistische bewegung stärker macht die
afg ist im tennis im bündnis mit päda
und bekennende nazis aufmarschiert sie
und ihre bündnispartner sind
stichwortgeber für rechts terroristen
wie die revolution chemnitz die gefahr
für die demokratie kommt nicht von den
muslimen sondern sie kommt von rechts
und genau deswegen werden wir am
wochenende gemeinsam mit vielen
zehntausend in berlin unter dem motto
hashtag und teil demonstrieren weil die
menschenrechte sind unteilbar christine
buchholz war das für die linksfraktion
es geht nach wie vor um einen antrag der
af.de der sich mit dem thema der wie die
fdp sagt unvereinbarkeit von islam
scharia und rechtsstaat befasst der
nächste redner ist christoph de vries
aus der unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich möchte eins zu beginnen feststellen
ihr antrag von der afg ist inhaltlich
komplett wird er lässt jede konkrete
politische forderungen vollständig
vermissen und der ist
gesellschaftspolitisch dieses motiv und
feindselig das muss erst mal vorab
gesagt werden
und es ist schon angesprochene
grundsätzliche bemerkungen auch nochmal
zum treff an der erleben ist jetzt zum
wiederholten male dass wichtige
gesellschaftspolitische verfassungsrecht
ein tag vor der beratung eingebracht
werden ich habe nochmal nachgeschaut
ihre mail ist am dienstagabend gekommen
als kein büro mehr besetzt war
faktisch haben wir das ein tag vorher
gehabt und und er baumann das ist nicht
nur das ist nicht nur höchst
unprofessionell dass es auch ein zeichen
mangelnden respekts im parlament
gegenüber und wer parlamentsarbeit so
dilettantisch betreibt er darf sich auch
nicht über kräftigen gegenwind hier aus
dem parlament wundern von uns können sie
noch eine menge lernen haben sie recht
so könnte man ja denken sie haben lange
gebraucht was lange währt wird endlich
gut aber weit gefehlt wenn wir auf ihr
dürftiges petit umschauen dann erschöpft
sich das alleine in der aufforderung an
die bundesregierung geeignete maßnahmen
zu ergreifen um die verbreitung
gesetzeswidriger koran inhalte zu
unterbinden
und da fragen wir uns wirklich ist das
alles was ihnen als antragsteller dazu
einfällt ist dass ihre politische
alternative eines kann ich ihnen
jedenfalls versichern wir tun das schon
lange meine damen und herren die
deutschen bundesregierung gehen seit
vielen jahren konsequent gegen
islamistische organisationen und
aktivitäten in deutschland vor
vielleicht kann ich kann ihm empfehlen
einen blick nur auf die homepage des
bundesinnenministeriums aber lesen sie
doch mal den verfassungsschutzbericht in
der vergangenheit hat es 21 verbote
gegeben im bereich des islamismus und
ausländerextremismus wegen aktivitäten
gegen unser verfassungsmäßige ordnung
zuletzt gegen die salafistische
organisation die wahre religion
sie sehen also unsere demokratie unser
rechtsstaat ist wehrhaft und das sollen
sie endlich auch mal anerkennen
und her und das ist doch gar keine ist
doch gar keine frage die scharia gehört
nicht zu unserem rechtsstaat weil sie
mit unserer demokratischen grundordnung
nicht vereinbar ist
ein fundamentalistischer islam dessen
ziel es ist unsere gesellschaft und
richtung eines gottesstaates zu
verändern kann nicht teilt deutschland
sein da sind wir doch einer meinung
und damit sind wir beim politischen
islam dass es den politischen islam gibt
ist kein hirngespinst es gibt zum
beispiel die ergebnisse einer
empirischen studie der uni münster mit
interessanten ergebnissen
sie wurde durchgeführt unter türkischen
muslimen ich will nur drei ergebnisse
nennen demnach um rund 20 prozent der
befragten eine negative einstellung
gegenüber juden und 50 prozent sagten
dass die befolgung der religiösen gebote
wichtiger sei als die staatlichen
gesetze und ein drittel sprach sich
dafür aus dass muslime die rückkehr zu
einer gesellschaftsordnung wie zumal mit
zeiten anstreben sollten
natürlich natürlich müssen uns solche
ergebnisse mit sorge erfüllen im blick
auf das zusammenleben und den
gesellschaftlichen frieden aber das ist
nur die eine seite der medaille die
andere seite ist doch die rund 20
prozent der türkischstämmigen muslime
vorbehalte gegen juden haben habe ich 80
prozent nicht und das sind 455 und das
ist noch die große mehrheit und und zwei
drittel wollen auch keine
gesellschaftsordnung wie zumal mit
zeiten und ich finde das ist doch
ermutigen meine damen und herren und
darauf sollten wir aufbauen und ehrlich
gesagt noch eine bemerkung am rande wenn
man sich die äußerung für eine afd
vertreter so anhört dann könnte man im
übrigen meinen dass der anteil der
antisemiten hf die deutlich über 20
prozent liegt aber das vielleicht nur
zurück zum thema insofern ist es stimmt
es nicht dass die scharia untrennbar mit
dem islam verbunden ist wie sie
behaupten diese unterstellung ist
böswillig diskriminieren und sie ist
auch destruktiv und ihnen geht es nicht
um den gesellschaftlichen frieden bei
uns im lande
sie wollen den islam und seine gläubigen
insgesamt diskreditieren und da spielen
wir nicht mit
bei uns ist nämlich eine entscheidende
frage
beginnen wir mit diesem
fundamentalistischen strömungen um die
es geht wie kann es gelingen den
gesellschaftlichen frieden zu verbessern
dieser konstruktiver ansatz wo es doch
handlungsleitend für uns sein als
politiker und da sage ich ihnen unser
ziel ist dass wir die liberalen muslime
stärken die sich zur freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung bekennen
die vor allem säkulären islam stehen die
sich unserem land verbunden führen und
dass wir gleichzeitig den einfluss der
radikalen kräfte unterbieten wir als
bundesregierung als koalition verfolgen
diese ziele konsequent zuletzt mir die
mittel an die tib im übrigen des
strichen ab dem haushalt 2018
wir werden das auch bei anderen vereinen
und verbänden machen wenn von der
metallische aktivität nachweisbar sind
sie sehen also wir führen diese kunst
debatten in aller klarheit aber mit
einem ziel das friedliche miteinander zu
stärken die gegenseitigen respekt so
schnell ihre religion zu stärken und so
machen wir politik vielen dank das wort
hat die abgeordnete dr frauke petry
sehr geehrte präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren leider ist
diese debatte mit wenigen ausnahmen
anreden hat zum wiederholten male ein
eindrückliches beispiel dafür warum
bürger dieses landes immer wieder den
eindruck haben dass sich ihre
lebenswirklichkeit in diesem hause nur
unzureichend widerspiegelt man muss der
einsicht raf die mitnichten folgen und
sachlich mit den anträgen der stimme und
ansonsten kinkerlitzchen spielchen
übersandt förmchen zu unterlassen das
müssen wir unbedingt
lassen sie mich daher eine frage stellen
gehört die scharia in all ihren
varianten wenn sie mögen für deutschland
und die antwort lautet leider ja bereits
2011 warnten die juristen joachim wagner
und sehr an artist dass ich im schatten
des deutschen rechtsstaates an die
islamische parallel christi zu etabliert
hat immerhin geben einige von ihnen das
sogar zu mit friedens richtern und sogar
mit staatlicher zusammenarbeit deutscher
behörden mit imamen
der rechtsstaat hat sein gewaltmonopol
nicht nur in stadtgebieten mit kühlen
sondern heimlich still und leise an
vielen orten unseres landes abgegeben
und vor der scharia egal in welcher
variante kapituliert um es ganz
unmissverständlich zu sagen der islam
ist nicht deckungsgleich mit kultur
muslimen die säkularisiert sind die
unsere rechtsprechung als maßgeblich
ansehen aber wenn wir vor der scharia
einknicken oder ist es egal ob es ein
drittel sind oder 40 prozent der als
jeder einer zu viel
dann verraten wir gerade jene menschen
die sich von dieser religiösen bevor man
befreit haben und erweisen wir genau
diesen auch verklärten menschen einen
bärendienst
und ja fragen sie auch die experten
religionswissenschaftler die utopie des
euro oder deutschen islam ist längst
bewiesen ist längst diskutiert ihn gibt
es nicht und wird ihn auf absehbare zeit
nicht geben selbst der vordenker des
euro islams bassam tibi und sieht diese
idee als gescheitert an
und das sollten wir als politiker zur
kenntnis nehmen und nichts zu tun als
wüssten wir es besser
im übrigen schon thomas mann liegt im
jesuiten nacht die worte in den mund ein
liberalisierter islam
das ist aufgeklärt der fanatismus und
wenn sie ein aktuelles beispiel
bevorzugen ein blick in die ehemalig
laizistische türkei gemüt und besitzen
genug kollegen in dem haus die die
zustände türkei sehr zutreffend
kritisieren
daraus folgt dass es ebenso verkehrt ist
alle muslime über einen kamm zu scheren
als auch den islam und seine blutige
vergangenheit die gegenwart zu
verharmlosen und somit maßgeblich durch
wegschauen zum deutschen antisemitismus
problem beizutragen wenn es ihnen also
ein friedliches rechtsstaatlich
zusammenleben in deutschland geht dann
lassen sie uns behörden und justiz in
der konsequenten anwendung unseres
rechtssystems bestärken sogenannte
kultur rabatte darf es dann nicht geben
genau die sind aber realität in
deutschland
die fraktionslose abgeordnete frauke
petry und ist es immer wieder
faszinierend die ehemalige fdp
vorsitzende hat ja dinge gesagt ich im
grunde auch gottfried kurios der afg
fraktion vorhin vorgetragen hatte aber
aus den reihen der fdp fraktion regt
sich keine hand zu ihrem redebeitrag der
vorletzte redner in der debatte ist lars
castellucci migrations und
integrationspolitischer sprecher der spd
fraktion auf der grundlage dieses
antrags
als ich anfang 20 war daten wir das wort
zur gemeinsamen wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen lage der kirchen in deutschland
und da haben wir aufgetragen bekommen
schaut doch mal im osten was wir da
lernen können bildet runde tische und
schaut ob wir nicht probleme im
miteinander im miteinander lösen können
in diesem land und dann haben wir den
runden tisch für arbeit gegründet in
meine heimatstadt und eine
beschäftigungsinitiative daraus
entstanden die heute noch arbeitet und
eine kleine sozialunternehmer
geworden ist es menschen perspektiven
bietet dann war wir bei grün-rot in
baden-württemberg und wir haben mit
sozialministerin altpeter den aktiv
passiv tausch erfunden und wieder
modellprojekte gemacht und geschaut
arbeit finanzieren nicht
arbeitslosigkeit und es hat wieder
vielen menschen geholfen aber nur mit
den möglichkeiten eines bundeslandes und
heute endlich kommen wir einen
riesenschritt voran beim nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt endlich freue mich
darauf dass wir endlich ein großes
programm haben um menschen die am
arbeitsmarkt schwierigkeiten haben nach
vorne zu bringen und ihnen zu helfen
ihnen die teilhabe zu ermöglichen und
das sind die botschaften die eigentlich
ins land müssen nun nicht das was hier
wieder vorgelegt wurde
oder wir hätten länger über den letzten
tagesordnungspunkt reden müssen dass wir
familien entlasten müssen und dass wir
das über den solidaritätszuschlag machen
und dass wir das mit dem kindergeld
machen aber dass zum beispiel wir
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
dabei gar nicht stehen bleiben wollen
das ist natürlich darum geht dass uns in
diesem land jedes kind gleich viel wert
sein muss dass wir nicht dabei stehen
bleiben wollen dass kinder von eltern
die mehr verdienen am ende vom staat
mehr geld bekommen als kinder von eltern
die nicht so viel verdienen wir haben
noch viel vor bei der die kinderarmut in
diesem land nicht akzeptieren wollte und
zurückbringen müssen die debatte hätten
wir noch locker eine stunde länger
führen können anstatt diesen antrag
hierzu beraten
aber sie fordern mich auch zum thema
zumindest können sie jetzt gerne haben
ich sage ihnen dieser antrag ist
schlecht ist ungenau es verleumderisch
als unverschämt und mehr ist dazu
eigentlich gar nicht zu sagen
sie führe hier den islam aus politischem
kalkül sie haben sogar eine debatte über
gelder für den zentralrat der juden in
der letzten sitzungswoche dazu
missbraucht hier die religionsfreiheit
anzugreifen und islam hass zu schüren
das ist zum fremdschämen was sie hier
jede woche vorlegen
ihr antrag ist eine einzige
zahnschmelzes lecke muslime in diesem
land zu stigmatisieren aber die mehrheit
der muslime in diesem land steht zur
demokratie und ist loyal zu unserem land
und sie haben es nicht verdient von
ihnen pauschal in eine ecke gestellt zu
werden
wissen sie was ich eigentlich tritt
landeskindern sie deuten den gesamten
islam fundamentalistisch aus aha das
machen aber die fundamentalisten auch
damit offenbaren sie ihre eigene
geisteshaltung zwischen dem was die
fundamentalisten vortragen und dem was
sie hier vortragen über den islam passt
nämlich kein blatt papier
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
unter grundgesetz ist ein gutes und
gesetzt wir haben die religionsfreiheit
die für uns alle gilt wir haben ein
grundgesetz dass wir durchsetzen wollen
gesetz und recht gelten für alle
parallel justiz lehnen wir ab es ist
rechtswidrig gehen dagegen vor es wird
nicht geduldet wir brauchen in diesem
land zusammen führende debatten
wir brauchen eine benennung von problem
und wir brauchen problemlösungen wir
brauchen keine anträge die nur neue
probleme schaffen
vielen dank lars castellucci war das der
migrations und integrationspolitische
sprecher der spd bundestagsfraktion und
da sind wir folgerichtig beim letzten
redner angekommen immer jung wird das
seien aus den reihen der unions fraktion
und dann sind wir mit diesem
tagesordnungspunkt auch schon durch frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren es
ist nicht so ganz einfach nach einer
stunde debatte über einen antrag zu dem
es eigentlich nicht viel zu sagen gibt
jetzt noch was neues zu sagen deswegen
versuche ich mich ein bisschen auf das
zu beschränken was oder ein bisschen was
aufzunehmen was du schon gehört haben
oder vielleicht auch mal jemanden
anderen hier was lesen wenn zu aller
erst sagen ich war ja sehr gespannt auf
diesen antrag weil wir haben vor zwei
wochen ja schon mal über
religionsfreiheit hier gesprochen
da gab es ein antrag auf änderung des
grundgesetzartikels 18
da hat die afg hier nachhaltig behauptet
artikel 4 des grundgesetzes die
religionsausübung freiheit zumindest
dürfe überhaupt nicht eingeschränkt
werden zwei vorbehaltlos gewährt
kollidieren nicht mit anderen
grundrechten und müsse daher in die
verwirkung silva aufgenommen werden
jetzt in ihrem antrag
schreiben sie das was stimmt zwar ist er
im wortlaut vorbehalten uns gewehrt aber
natürlich kontrolliert er immer mit
anderen grund rechnung kann nur soweit
gewährt werden ausgeübt werden wie nicht
rechnen andere betroffen sind da haben
sie ein stück weit dazu gelernt ich
welchen dankbar wenn sie das
fraktionsinternen mal an die
rechtspolitiker weitergeben dass diese
erkenntnis dort auch herrscht von denen
haben sie heute dann niemand mehr reden
lassen so einem thema das eigentlich
rechts politisches und dann meinen armen
tagen haben wir mit spannung auf diesen
antrag gewartet und herr baumann ich
verstehe ja dass ich ein stück weit um
ihren job kämpfen sich rechtfertigen
müssen in der eigenen fraktion
aber sie können jetzt noch 100 mal
erzählen dass sie den früh genug
eingereicht hätten den antrag am
mittwochmittag war zumindest nicht
hochgeladen und alle rechtspolitiker der
afg haben im ausschuss unisono gesagt
sie kennen keinen antrag vielleicht
stecken sind dann mache ich eigene
fraktionen wenn sie vielleicht schicken
sind dann mal an die eigene fraktion
dann schicken sie ihn doch einfach
vielleicht auch an die eigene fraktion
dann können wir weiter geben kollege
sensburg hat danach gefragt hat keine
antwort bekommen so dann haben wir
diesen antrag bekommen und ich frage
mich bis heute was wollen sie eigentlich
erreichen
da sind sachen drin die stimmen
gesetzwidrige religionsausübung darf
nicht gewählt werden ja hetze gegen
andere darf nicht geduldet werden ja
stimmt und dann benennen sie die
repressiven maßnahmen teilweise selbst
der sensburg hat sie noch ergänzt 111
106 39 95 und 1872 haben wir alles die
vereinsverbote ja sensburg genannt hat
sogar präventive maßnahmen gibt's da
hätten sie vielleicht auch etwas
vorschlagen können definiert sich alle
wiederholen die hat ebenfalls reagiert
der doktor hoffmann ist doch nix wissen
sollte hoffmann entschuldigung mehr als
er kurz kurz probiert man in ihnen
ebenfalls doch wo ist wo ist ihr
vorschlag wo ist ihr vorschlag sex
zweiten antrag einzig eine bitte an die
bundesregierung sie möge mal was
vorschlagen wo sie ihr vorschlag sie
machen einfach nur einen
antwortschreiben sex hatten was zusammen
und dann kann man nur das vermuten was
hat doch der produkte fechner
angesprochen haben dass es ihnen
möglicherweise darum geht den koran zu
verbieten weiß nicht wie das gehen soll
verbrennen oder wie auch immer im
digitalen zeitalter wenn sie keine
schrift mehr loswerden
deswegen haben die es wahrscheinlich
auch bewusst gar nicht geschrieben aber
mir ist nicht klar worauf sie eigentlich
hinaus wollen mal nahmen 91 möchte ich
damit kein falscher zungenschlag
reinkommt auch für die cdu csu klar
stellt wir wollen das problem nicht
verharmlosen deswegen arbeiten wir ja
seit jahren daran das haben die kollegen
gezeigt natürlich gibt es innerhalb
des islams fundamentalistische
bestrebung natürlich gibt es dort auch
welche die sich rechtswidriger weise
aufschriften berufen aber das dulden wir
eben nicht meine damen und herren und an
der stelle und an der stelle möchte ich
aber auch für meine fraktion 1 noch
einmal klarstellen die vergleiche zum
christentum
herr martens frau buchholz frau polat
die wir gehört haben mögen in der
schrift richtig sei aber ich möchte
schon auch mal festhalten dass das
berufen bei straftaten auf die heilige
schrift seit der aufklärung im
christentum doch etwas nachgelassen hat
im vergleich zu heute und vielleicht
sollten wir das an der stelle dann auch
mal sagen als christdemokratische
fraktion und liebe kollegen von der afd
wenn wir beim christentum sind ich habe
mir gerade mal weil ja doch alles schon
gesagt wurde im kirchheimer was
angeschaut wenn sie hier das christliche
abendland dauernd verteidigen
dann ist die statistik die wir dort
lesen können wie viele ihrer eigenen
fraktion sich überhaupt zu einer
christlichen konfession bekennen doch
recht ganz interessant irgendwie waren
es gar nicht gewusst bei der cdu csu
sind es 205 und 246 das sind 83,3
prozent bei der afg sind 16 von 92 das
sind 17,4 prozent dreieinhalb prozent
weniger als die grünen also das war hier
wirklich erstaunlich meine damen und
herren das sind
das sind also die verteidiger des
christlichen abendlandes
das finde ich schon starke sache
insgesamt mein name karmann zu ihrem
antrag nur eins sagen wie gesagt sie
machen kann vorschlag aber eins ist klar
dass teilen glaube ich alle fraktionen
hier im parlament wer glaubt sich
außerhalb unserer rechtsordnung bewegen
zu können das gilt nicht nur für
islamisten das gilt für alle der bekommt
es bei uns in einem rechtsstaat zu tun
völlig egal worauf er sich beruft
offenbar wissen sie dass auch deswegen
machen sie keinen neuen vorschlag denken
sie mich noch mal nach herzen immer jung
für die unionsfraktion war der letzte
redner zu einem antrag aus den reihen
der fdp fraktion zum thema islam und
rechtsstaat ist wiederholt reklamiert
worden dass die fdp zwar forderungen
aufstellt aber selber keine vorschläge
macht zu geben in diesem problembereich
wohingegen das in den vergangenen jahren
durchaus immer wieder verbotene
islamistische organisationen in
deutschland gegeben habe um eben die
verbreitung gesetz wie die regulären
hier auch zu verhindern